so what's working right now on YouTube
to get views and subscribers and this
training we're going to be breaking down
some simple strategies that can help you
grow your channel break through a
plateau maybe you're feeling stuck or
maybe you're just frustrated because
you're not sure what's wrong when it
comes to your content your strategy and
I want to encourage you if you're
watching this video check out the time
codes and chapters because
um we're going to be talking about
different niches different topics and
maybe your topic will get covered as
well as some questions and maybe some
specific pain points you're experiencing
when it comes to YouTube and so if
you're fired up smash like and I want to
welcome Dan from vid IQ who's going to
be co-hosting today Dan welcome thank
you for having me I'm super grateful to
have you on and uh we're gonna dive
first into a channel from our VRA
community and it is the true crime Niche
a very popular Niche on YouTube and uh
this is the description here it's called
killer Cafe are you fascinated by True
Crime things spooky we can uh dive over
here to shorts
looks like we've got some shorts going
on not many and we've had as many as 530
views on the shorts and then on our full
length videos it looks like there's a
podcast here kind of cool that there is
a new podcast feature on YouTube
that would be a new tab and it connects
over to YouTube music This is Aang
welcome to
the
um this is a trailer it looks like and
maybe it hasn't quite started so that
looks like that's the vision there smart
because True Crime crime podcasts are
very popular and we've only been doing
it for two months so we're really just
getting started and you can obviously
see the main videos here with some
thumbnails going on some of the view
counts as high as 190 views so off to a
really great start is my first
impression but Dan I would love to hear
your insights and feedback on some
improvements and tips that we could all
learn from yeah this is a really good
start for just a couple months on
YouTube so welcome to YouTube honestly
and uh you know this is awesome to see
so I think uh you know we we can talk
about you know thumbnails a little bit
I'm really I was focused on the the
titles for sure uh because when you look
at these uh there's there's one thing
that's standing out to me with these
titles and that's that these are great
titles for books right like uh the
ghosts that haunt us and the media that
changed it I I think for YouTube videos
like if I'm uh if I'm somebody who's
never seen your channel before I'm
scrolling through YouTube and this video
pops up as a recommended video the
ghosts that haunt us and the media that
changed it
there's a lot of vagueness in that title
for me as as just a general YouTube
viewer and I'm sure the content is
really really solid but it it's just
it's titled too much like a book as the
best way I can put it culture and
beliefs it's a great tip and so some
improvement on the titles let's actually
dig into this uh very video and see what
we can learn from the hook here Staple
in human culture ghosts have been a
staple in human culture and beliefs for
many centuries from ancient Greeks and
Romans to Modern Day movies and TV shows
the idea of ghosts and spirit nice
little jump cut there so it looks like
she's crafting her intro and I'm not
sure if she's considering this a podcast
yet it is the killer Cafe podcast so
there are some episodes coming out so I
think that's also you know as we are
here on YouTube kind of fascinating to
consider that there's a whole other
angle of how you could would be getting
views that's kind of interesting that I
don't know what I just did there but uh
I clicked podcast and it took me away
from from our actual podcast even though
so this has been a feature that we could
all learn from if you click on the
killer Cafe podcast okay that I don't
know what happened with YouTube there
that would be the better so it brings
you to a playlist that playlist is a
list of what's in the podcast looks like
a short made it in here which I would
argue is maybe a mistake just because
what would the consumption of that be
but maybe it's not a big deal because
even if someone's listening on audio
could they get value out of that 14
seconds that's interesting okay so
anyways uh any thoughts on this I have a
hook here and I'm just like you know
kind of telling the story from a solo
round and narrating it's definitely
scripted and I like the fact that she
went in planned but what are your
thoughts
yeah I I think I think the hook there's
a making there's the makings of a really
good hook there it's something that
would take a little more practice but I
I think this this the way they did it is
they didn't introduce hey welcome back
to the channel I'm so and so and this is
what we're doing like they just got
straight into it which I love to see and
I think it it's just gonna be like a
matter of continuing to make videos but
when I heard that hook immediately title
ideas started popping into my head and
one of those ideas just to give you a
very basic understanding what I was
saying earlier about the the title of
your video the title for this video
could be something along the lungs of
why you should believe in ghosts or you
know here's why people believe in ghosts
or things like that because you're
talking about ghosts and like how long
people have believed in them why they do
so there's probably something in there
depending on where you go with your
video we're not obviously watching the
whole thing then you could craft a
really really good clickable title from
but when I was talking earlier about the
title being too vague that's kind of
what I was getting at is what is this
really about if it's about ghosts and
the history of ghosts and and spear and
things like that then there's a really
strong play there for a title that's
like you know why people believe in
ghosts in 2023 or something along those
lines uh so that'd be my advice there
and I think from knowing that title
ahead of time you can then think or
rethink the hook of a video and you can
go okay if that's what people are going
to see the moment they see my video
what's the first thing they should hear
man really good tips and you know we're
talking really kind of about we can talk
about the perfect video recipe
figured about the good thumbnail and
improvements could definitely be made on
the thumbnails here thinking about
um a better title I think I agree with
you very a lot of work could be done on
the titles and then and um and then kind
of the topic in general because
that right there is the topic but it's
kind of like how are you positioning the
topic and uh you know today's stream is
brought to you by vid IQ and we'll talk
a little bit more about this later but
if you haven't got the 30-day trial of
the Boost plan it's only one dollar and
some of the tools that I'm gonna dive
into right now are incredibly helpful
and one of those tools is the um there's
a link to that in the description and uh
one of those tools is the AI title
recommendations so as I typed in real
stories of ghosts kind of the angle
you're talking about Dan like terrifying
real life ghost stories you won't
believe compare terrifying real life
ghost stories you won't believe to
the channel That We're on of killer Cafe
to the ghosts that haunt us and the
media that changed it and so
um
yeah that's one of the powerful powerful
tools or you know unbelievable true
Tales of real ghosts and I think a
mistake that sometimes people can make
is that
they think their title
has to be
too practical or too
this is going to sound funny but even
like accurate it has to be honest but
the point of the title is just to get
someone interested in the episode then
it's realizing it's a progression thus
what you say in the hook might be
like you know are ghosts real well the
tail we're covering today is and then
you kind of Unbreak it and then you're
like the book name if it is some kind of
a book or whatever is if you were to say
and you need that quote unquote fact of
like the ghost that honest and the media
that changed it like that's the story or
that's the old newspaper you looked up
well you can say that later on so then
that's still you kind of lead to it but
starting with this viewer psychology
that's going to get the click in the
first place any final thoughts for how
she might grow her channel here
I think taking that advice to heart and
applying that to applying it to the
whole process of creating video you
could go back and change titles and
thumbnails but I would encourage you to
take what we're saying today if you if
you agree with this advice take it to
heart and work towards it on your next
video because what is really really
powerful is knowing the title and the
thumbnail and then planning your hook
around that because it's really the
trifecta
it's really good and you know her most
viewed video
is a lot clearer it's about a very
specific story Madeleine McCain
I would final tip eliminate the hashtag
I think it's
a hashtag could actually be added in the
description which would mean that it
ends up becoming clickable problem is
even the clickable hashtag right here if
I click on that chances are
it's going to take me away from your
channel it's taking me to new stations
it's taking me to other things so what
really what value did that hashtag add
other than perhaps associating you with
this conversation but it's not going to
really necessarily lead to Discovery and
because that's a blue clickable link it
actually could lead to distraction from
your content and so if that was just
spaced out but still the
the topic here and even the positioning
is
pretty powerful and it also success
leaves Clues it's your most viewed video
but I'd even go a step further to say
what was like the essence of the case is
it a
you know some type of uh what crime I'm
avoiding saying certain words just
because they might make the videos about
some some uh demonetized you know type
of but it probably doesn't matter I
don't think we'd get flagged in an
education video like this but you get
what I'm saying like
m-u-r-d-e-r or something some kind of uh
content like that because then or or was
it a kidnapping or was it something else
like I go through a list of sketchy
things that are like wow what is it Dan
and like are they teaching people how to
kidnap others okay so anyways uh but
really great start and two months in
it's good to see the hustle it's good to
see the hard work
um and so great job there uh by the way
if you're getting value smash like and
if you've got a question put four
question marks before and after we're
also gonna be taking your questions if
you are here live and uh
also I am not trying to be Cavalier with
this subject matter as well I'm not
actually sure the story there so I love
the empathy here in our community and I
don't know what the mysterious case is
but it sounds like it was a very awful
incident and so true crime
um with that let's jump into the next
channel here we're gonna check out
Malaya and her channel is a weekly dose
of motivation and a friendly reminder to
slow down so you can live intentionally
powerful premise and Topic in today's
world
um YouTuber lifestyle blogger is that
true it is okay so as we we read the
word blogger she in fact has a Blog
associated with this which is great very
powerful a long lost art maybe not long
and lost but for a lot of YouTube
creators that underestimate the power of
writing a Blog even perhaps occasionally
writing medium posts which is kind of a
social media
blog and you can have search and
Discovery for your brand or your content
man these days you can take videos and
turn them into blog posts relatively
easy with AI and
um let's check out some shorts here
we've
post some shorts as many as 1 700 views
and our main videos and the core of our
content
unbelievable tribute to women everywhere
you've got to see this seven minute
mirror meditation for inner peace
and if we go over to popular our best
video is slim down without starving I
can show you a non-diet approach secret
to weight loss
kind of a gnarly title good opening four
words because slim down without starving
kind of Rhymes but then it's like I can
show you the non-diet approach quote
unquote secret with the spaces to weight
loss a little long
bizarre quotations unnecessary it could
be kind of cleaned up besides perhaps
optimized it's a little with the title
case kind of title Case C technically
should be title case but and I don't
know if that would distract as many
people but it's um
all that to say it is also the most
highest performing video which shows
that you know small tweaks could lead to
Giant Peaks because even your content
with the most momentum I think there
could be some opportunities there so Dan
what are your thoughts
when I compare that video to the ones we
saw on the uh the home page for the
latest videos that video to me has like
a very direct purpose right it's it has
it's solving a problem
but some of the other videos on the
channel feel like if I watch them they
could they could solve a problem but
again we kind of go back to what I was
saying earlier it's a little vague like
there's a meditation for inner peace but
there's so many like meditation videos
out there you know is there could we
could we target a more specific audience
with that like meditation for people who
have no idea how to meditate you know
um seven tips for better meditation
practices like are there ways that you
can like frame this content to be you
know again more specific because that
video we saw a little while ago the top
videos way more specific
yeah it's very good and and calling out
a specific audience is one of the power
tips of the day for sure especially in a
noisy world where there could be even
simply saying for women or perhaps
saying for students because now their
mindset they're about to go to school
they want to get into the right and it
just it just is so much more powerful
you want to be a meaningful specific not
a Wandering generality and
these are some um we're using the vid IQ
AI title recommendations tool once again
it says get ready to transform your life
with these meditation tips for beginners
take a journey into mindful meditation
find out how learn how to harness calm
and happiness and five easy steps
there's kind of a tip too and that's
what's nice about a tool like this is
that you really want to be using these
tools
during the ideation process Dan and I
think would both recommend that it's a
good idea to have at least a strong idea
of what your title is going to be or
perhaps what your final title is title
is going to be before you even press
record because then you really know the
angle and you then perhaps know well you
only have three easy steps great so you
kind of reverse engineer that back and
then there's it's a little bit more
concrete but I love what Dan's saying in
terms of you know the most popular video
is
very specific pain point and
our VRA Community knows we teach asq
answer specific questions not just
answer questions
answer specific questions
and so one other thing we could do here
is we could take um
motivation okay so here so and I think
the power here is we are helping modern
women find happiness and success
um and
that right there could maybe be more
emphasized I think on the one hand you
might kind of assume because you're like
well they might see the thumbnail
they'll see me and you'll sort of
attract people that resonate with the
look of your thumbnail you and the
thumbnail whether they're going to click
or not however it's really helpful to
also call out the audience in the
specific situation and it sounds like
you're already doing that and you're
about page so how could you do that in
your
uh videos I'm gonna use the video Q AI
coach and say what are some video ideas
for a Channel about helping modern women
find happiness and success
kind of a
General premise somewhat but so many
specific opportunities within there and
so it's going to think about that
question right now and I'm going to pass
it back to you down for any tips right
now any strategies or video ideas you'd
recommend here in fact before I do that
let's get a let's get a um
let's get an idea of the content here
okay
I'm gonna jump in just briefly and say
okay it's very hard to read this text
and it's outside of title safe with
YouTube I mean the way we're looking at
it to all women I have to stretch for it
mothers grandmothers aunties and then
when text is over other texts sisters
other text and b-roll the text is
messing me up
[Music]
so if uh yeah go for it yeah so the
I like this in terms of how artistic it
is I would agree on the text for sure
but like the shots you're using in the
music
um it does the title is unbelievable
tribute so I suppose this is like as a
tribute video this kind of makes sense I
guess but uh I am I I guess it's that
comes back to being really really clear
in the title in the thumbnail right like
I wasn't sure what we were gonna get and
the music and the text and things like
that it's it's kind of like okay this
this looks nice but it who is it for
necessarily is kind of what I asked
myself I know it's it's specifically a
tribute to women but
when you just think about like the
YouTube homepage on its own like you you
look at videos and they're all trying to
convince you to like click on them so
someone like takes a chance on that
video and they click on it
is it delivering on the click and I it's
hard to say there's like no real host in
the video there's no one kind of pulling
me in it's kind of like almost like a
movie trailer in a sense but I didn't
really get that from the time on the
thumbnail
yes very good point that video nice
tribute not the strongest topic not the
strongest content let's give one shot
here to a woman's guide to putting
herself first and kind of see what we're
doing hi my name is maeva and I'm
selfish hi ladies welcome or welcome
back to my channel let's talk about
being I kind of like the hook because
it's uh
you know it's kind of controversial it's
true for everybody but it's something we
probably would uh you know not say and
it's cool that you said it
um and but I think it needed to breathe
you rock it my name is and I'm selfish
hi my name is Marva
and I'm selfish
and then I mean just just subtle because
it went so fast it took me a while to
process hi ladies welcome or welcome and
then it's of course like oh where's she
going with this that's bold a channel
let's talk about being selfish I don't
understand why the word selfish has had
a bad reputation when in fact it is one
off to my opinion one of the healthiest
choice you can ever thoughts on this
hook van I love the hook I I think
that's really awesome and I loved where
it was going too uh I I'm gonna like
just my my tip for that video
specifically is there's so many other
contexts where you can tell someone
where they should be selfish in life you
could you could have people being
selfish in terms of work people being
selfish in terms of like taking time for
themselves even though they're busy and
they have a family like there's so many
different angles and I feel like again
if this Creator were to get specific
about at least in each video if not
throughout the entire Channel who they
want to speak to like who directly they
want to reach every single time well
like that channel could take off like I
I really love the way they talk and
present a topic like they pulled me
right in and I wanted to see where that
was going but just from like a YouTube
growth perspective it's going to help
you so much to know like who are you
trying to encourage to be selfish
selfish excuse me like is it is it just
women all like in general and the answer
you want to say is probably yes but I
think if you were to Branch out to that
slowly over time and like just just hone
that in even more like really try and
Niche down more I think that'll help a
ton
so one of the things we're going to look
at here is one of the powerful tools
that is in vid IQ boost there is some
free features here but to really unlock
it it's the AI coach and
um
if we dive into this what I did earlier
was I prompted the AI coach
and I said what are some video ideas for
a Channel about helping modern women
find happiness and success so here's
some video ideas in the way that they're
framing them up but it goes a lot deeper
than video ideas for this channel
it gives you a title a kind of a
description so you know the angle a
thumbnail idea
an idea for the length of the video and
your target audience
um for even the age group and I want to
even think about before we dive into
this like these are some of the nuances
that can take your YouTube channel to
another level meaning I was just
thinking about
uh I just saw somebody was celebrating
their birthday or they were turning 28
in the greater economy and I was like
wow I turned 40 this year I was like
that's 12 years younger than me I was
like that's an entirely different set of
songs that's an entire at high school
it's an entirely different set of
memories there's some overlaps maybe
they were in this vintage which would
have been my like non-vintage
um in terms of songs they grew up with
or whatever and so I think about a
really good book Pat Flynn super fans
and that some of the things perhaps if
you're maybe you grew up listening to
Backstreet Boys and you loved in sync
for me it was like I literally performed
New Kids on the Block in a talent show
like I'm that's old but all that to say
is if you kind of know who you're
talking to that's the point knowing who
you're talking to perhaps what are some
jokes or cultural events or
illustrations or metaphors related to
the audience but here's the idea is 10
happy habits for a happier and more
successful life
share some practical daily habits that
can help modern women achieve happiness
and success in their professional lives
and then the thumbnail a smiling women
with a checklist or a planner okay cool
you know you start thinking through that
shoot for 10 minutes and let's just go
through the other titles here an
overconfident how to overcome imposter
syndrome and boost your confidence
finding work-life balance tips for the
busy Modern Woman good title
and then I love because it could be
sometimes concrete could be five tips
for the busy Modern Woman and that may
or may not actually help it perform it's
not even that the number would help it
perform more but certain learning styles
know that sets expectations going into
it and it could create hunger
to learn all five tips the power of
networking how to build meaningful
connections unlock your full potential
tips for personal and professional
growth and we're not just looking at
ideas here but even just kind of the
angle and so
um this is why we love tools like this
you got to understand that the thinking
and the psychology and the mindset and
that's why being on kind of a group
coaching training like this that could
be helpful but then tapping into a tool
like that IQ and especially the brand
new AI coach can be incredibly helpful
we're going to take a couple questions
and if you are getting value so far uh
hit like and the way questions Stand Out
is by either saying question I like how
you did that Ken or putting four
question marks before and after
we were doing a travel channel Niche on
YouTube but our roadblock is we don't
really travel as much as probably two to
three times a year should we move to a
different niche
for equal opportunities for the word
Niche and Niche uh but
it's still related to travel Dan what's
your thoughts
well I would say when you do travel uh
you should collect as much as possible
like while you're out like what I mean
could by collect is like get footage get
get everything you can and really
between trips I'd be planning out
content before the next one this is if
you continue going down this road of
travel plan uh if you continue going
down this road of Travel Channel
um if you want content in between one
thing that I think would be really
helpful for people who watch Channels
like that assume you have an audience of
people who are interested in traveling
themselves what have you learned as
somebody who travels a lot and can you
share those tips with people can you
share products with people can you
review different types of products just
for pure search based videos that can
help people like maybe there's charging
organizers for like different phones
that have different ports like maybe
maybe you have like luggage hacks maybe
maybe there's just all kinds of
different things that you've picked up
and they kind of take for granted that
you're really good at that other people
would appreciate learning from so
there's a lot of different opportunities
there if you want to stay within that
kind of Niche without looking at the
channel it's hard to say like you know
specific ideas for you but that's what
I'd be thinking is like what can where
can you take that uh in between trips
that you're going on
solid advice our next Channel we're
gonna start right off with the video
that's set as their intro video or their
home page video or their unsubs not
subscribed yet video and let's check it
out
hello there you ever wanted your space
to feel like a warm hug full of
nostalgia like your grandma's living
room and make it
aesthetic and you're in the right place
this is the wood accent wall of your
dreams
why am I so dressed up in my desk
what can I say
so man this is
a really great hook
um and your
aesthetic your Vibe your humor your
personality
even the way you crafted your intro is
also strong but the audio quality and
the level of volume on the Audio I just
want to confirm also measure
um Dan are you hearing the same thing
hello there yeah it's paint it's like oh
yeah it's kind of too faint and and this
makes me think it's a good principle for
us to learn it makes me think for
example like for comedy to work you've
got to hear it like the punch line needs
to be Punchy
um and those Details Matter what's also
interesting is as we get into it eight
feet if your ceilings are higher than
eight feet you'll also measure for the
bottom panels my wall was 11 by 12. it
sounds like you're doing a a
voice over with some type of a
you know better microphone I started out
with a handsaw but we quickly and this
is all amazing and so cutter was the
easiest the humor in the beginning let's
see this too I'm feeling excited again
that also this also sounds great so just
the on-camera microphone something about
and and one of the things we would
consider is if you want a whisper to be
Punchy it's a whole art form of either
using video editing or getting a
microphone closer or and if if you I
definitely get the vibe it's so strong
but it's and everything about even
showing some of the Retro and then
having the props or the wine glass
that's so great
but the audio is too quiet and it and it
doesn't quite hook you and what's kind
of fascinating is
one of the biggest mistakes I made
earlier on in my YouTube career I don't
know if it's a mistake probably bothered
a lot of people is I just yelled all the
time
I was always cranked up on energy and I
was always yelling
one of the reasons why was
I was I grew up
with a lot of shotgun microphones on a
camera
10 feet away from them so it was kind of
a style of communication or low quality
gear because I started doing video in
2003 and what I didn't realize or I had
to like retrain my brain for was the
fact that we can come into a microphone
like this and let me know in the
comments if you can still hear me pretty
clear
and if you could join me for the
Romantic radio hour with Sean Cannell
I'm excited to meet you and that perhaps
the quality of your microphone can and
your understanding of the distance from
your microphone and all those types of
things
can be very helpful and I think that
takes this video from it looks all it's
already great I mean it's broken up it
looks like you narrate it through it
you've got the Vlog in in there and just
the amazing comedy intro
but the audio is a little weak Dan any
thoughts on that video before we look at
the whole Channel I loved that you took
a DIY project and like tried to tell a
story you know it's not just like the
step by step on how you're going to do
the thing today it you really like
brought us in there you showed your
personality like that's the kind of
thing that I think sets creators apart
you know from you from the like the
tacticians who are just going to teach
you how to make a DIY wall to from the
people who are going to make it a
memorable experience and and this is the
kind of Creator who could see themselves
in the future branching out in different
ways thanks to the community that are
likely building and just the their level
of like storytelling and professionalism
yep well put and and uh this does look
so the other good news about all of that
I mean with 21 Total videos on the
channel
I think that you are off for an
incredible start and your future is very
bright on YouTube so we're talking about
dreaming of big ideas DIY furniture home
decor walls photo shoots and um
we've got a few shorts already so
even shorts are part of that and some of
the shorts as much as five thousand
200 views on a short let's see
what is happening here
it's great ties into the channel
jump cut through mate did you just take
this for short or did you just reuse the
footage because this would be the way to
do it to take maybe that was also a long
form video and then just what's the 60
second version I think it's very
entertaining to watch and the scenes
happen
quickly enough the cuts and
this is also a top performing short that
is very on brand for your Channel
all of you're off to just like a very I
like how clear it feels
in terms of the promise and it's a good
it's a strong Niche home decor accent
walls you have a strong aesthetic in a
certain Unique Style to it all so the
shorts are are helpful there and then
let's finally look at some of these
videos and I would love to hear Dan's
thoughts on the thumbnails and anything
else and ideas for the channel
I would be looking because I this is not
a space that I like fully understand or
have experience with so I would be
looking at other DIY style channels that
kind of do these types of thumbnails
where it's you know they're they're
trying to go for the aesthetic of the
room and things like that because
normally I would say oh you're kind of
relying on a lot of text and things like
that but if I recall in this Niche this
is actually a pretty common way to do
things but again it's going to come down
to thumbnail research I think thumbnails
could be improved but I hesitate to
recommend anything too specific because
I want you to do that thumbnail research
Sean's gonna throw something in right
now just to see what we get uh and this
is this is the kind of stuff you guys
could be doing as you look to make
incremental improvements here we go
because it definitely is she definitely
at least some of her content is kind of
a retro DIY these top ones definitely
thumbnail best practice so minimalist
and clear great photography camera
angles lens choice
and simple text also using kind of
simpler more unique less distinct than
the typical block YouTube text that
everybody does but because it's readable
what's nice here though is because there
is enough Simplicity there it is still
easy to read the words more so in the
building a vinyl cabinet one here we
also have the rehab life on an easy
mid-century strong word you start
getting into of course something like
mid-century and you start thinking about
how tools like vid IQ could help you
dive deep into keywords and related
keywords and clusters of topics and
ideas around mid-century modern or
whatever Direction you want to take
things but uh yeah I think that also the
poor and after one of my
one of my favorite and one of the
classic YouTube thumbnail templates what
what pain Point does the audience have
before and after
what is their face look like before what
does it look like after what does it
look like with no costume what does it
look like after what does it look like
in chaos what does it look like after we
did a video on white balance
what my camera's all yellow and white
balance is wrong and it looks horrible
and now it looks great and crispy and
the colors are perfect that's oh that's
my desired result and so you can tell a
story in two frames some good thumbnail
tips there
um one other thing I noticed was just
circling back it would appear
that this that 60 Seconds
sofa thing
at least I saw it in the thumbnail
because it looked like you were doing
yeah it looks like this is the one you
were doing
and this looks I think the lesson here
which you're already doing it it's good
for our entire community
is how many ways you can slice and dice
up your content
like you actually did the project great
that's a short you've got this video
which it looks like oh the budget
breakdown so then you've got the budget
breakdown which is a whole nother video
and then I would imagine that here would
be the actual
um
original video and in this it looks like
you're going through all of the clips
and just doing these
horizontal landscape clips
you were able to edit these together
into a short and that became your most
viewed short
second major power tip of the day one
project one especially set of footage
was DJ'd out into at least three
different remixes three different
versions
a long form video a video just breaking
down the budget and a short
and as I know you're watching this right
now you're probably busy how do I get it
all done I'm juggling life kids family
school and this is the kind it's this is
like a not it's not just batching it's
another level than batching it's like
really strategically thinking about and
it would perhaps this one is also on the
same uh sofa it looks like and look at
all the views she's pulling from this
content it's very inspiring this looks
like the original
I don't know but so much great energy so
much good filming good everything and
and
I think what's cool is you know you're
getting 2723
views a month
new subscribers four uploads like you're
off to again an incredible start and it
looks like you know got started about
eight months ago I would I would push
for maybe more consistency after eight
months 21 videos
what is that Dan
oh gosh I don't know I wasn't I wasn't
here to do math I'm not good at math I
mean what does 21 divided by eight is
that how you do it yeah yeah about two
and a half videos a month so and by the
way
uh you might say on with everything I'm
doing I'm very busy well then then great
keep that pace up but one of the things
here you're putting out great content
you've had some breakout shorts It's
just that reminder that sometimes it's
about doubling down and doubling our
videos if you want to double your views
double your uploads
and that's not a perfect equation but if
you've consistently figured out how to
get content that gets at 500 views or a
thousand views and you upload two of
those you'll probably get two thousand
views but what happens mathematically is
if you upload four of those well one get
600 one gets a thousand one gets ten
thousand because that was your breakout
video and then one gets 5500 and so it
is not meant to be
um like Sean obviously if I want more
views on YouTube I should upload more
videos and that's not always the case
I'm talking about as you're following
Morgan the VRA 7rs I can tell and you're
you know adding value and you're
creating great content you've got great
energy you've got that going and you
have figured out how to make some good
videos If you apply some of the tips we
have here but find a way to increase
your frequency I think that growth will
grow looks like we have a special guest
oh they just left who is this Dan who's
joining us today on the think media
podcast this is for brat McGee
um no YouTube tips in in their brain
it's kind of empty in there
and I apologize
uh I love it for Brad any
um animal lovers shout us out smash the
like button if you are team dog let me
know if you're team cat let me know if
your team bird let me know and we're
gonna take a question from home studio
Academy I'm about a year in
780 Subs
1760 watch hours I believe I can meet
the 1000 Subs within two to three months
but
what advice
do you have Dan for increasing watch
hours
so watch hours there's a couple things
you could do uh a lot of people say you
make longer videos but that comes with a
quality aspect as well you don't want to
just fluff up your videos because people
will leave the videos if they don't feel
like there's any value and then you
actually hurt yourself in the process
one thing that you can do what I've done
in the past with channels I've helped
get monetized is live streams if those
are kind of outside of what you would
like to do I you know I'd still
encourage you to maybe test it out it
doesn't hurt to try live streaming those
watch hours do count and things can kind
of snowball pretty quickly if you have
that many subscribers already if you if
you have like a decent amount of views
you might be surprised how many people
join you for a live stream and if you
leave those live streams up the watch
hours you get from those also help I see
that your name is home studio Academy so
I'm assuming
um you know you're helping people with
like setups things like that what if you
did a live stream similar what we're
doing where you kind of reviewed
people's setups you know you get them in
ahead of time use the community tab to
like get some in pictures things like
that give them a form to like submit
them on and then you know you spend like
a half hour just kind of reviewing
people's setups so playing with new
content ideas things like that even if
they're not live streams I I'd be
testing out different formats of content
and just keep uploading you know those
watch hours will eventually accumulate
it is the most frustrating part I think
the monetization process but you will
get there
so strong
we are going to jump into a couple more
specific Channel topics
um these channels are from our video
ranking Academy Community we're not
taking any live new channel reviews
we are going to answer some more
questions so hit me with a couple
question marks before and after your
question and then today's stream is also
brought to you by vidiq and I wanted to
show you one other thought
for our for Morgan's Channel but to get
access to these amazing good IQ tools
and to get a 30-day trial of it iq's
boost plan for just one dollar you can
go to vidiq.com forward slash think and
there's a link in the description uh I
see Morgan is here with us Morgan
um hope this has been valuable for you
and
we also
um see a lot of people voting beautiful
kitty we have some team cat here team
team dog team cat team cat
team furberry fur baby is a wait team
fur baby good in a Furby baby be either
a dog or a cat Dan yeah I think they're
saying they would take either which what
a what a diplomatic answer yeah yeah
because otherwise it seems like there's
a lot of
um animosity and a lot of uh kind of a a
brewing War happening in our comments no
that's I'm just kidding I know y'all all
love and respect each other's opinion on
um on this and the Carriage House who
was reviewed on the show last time
she really actually has it right over
everybody team cat dog bird and horse so
why not take it to a whole other level
but I wanted to um
just go back to what I was discussing
especially to go deeper because I know
the majority of our VRA Community our
vid IQ users either the Pro Plan or the
Boost plan
and one of one of the tools first of all
you definitely want to be going to
app.vidiq.com you can use a lot of these
tools overlaid just up here at the top
and jump straight to like the keyword
inspector but my hunch was you know
mid-century modern as we talked about
earlier for Morgan's Channel and the key
is to
focus in on
a breadcrumb if you will a topic a
subject matter that you could start
digging deeper on
pull a thread and just see where it
leads and so what's cool here is we can
dive in and look at
related keywords and then look at the
search volume to perhaps see
in what could be vintage Decor or older
Decor
retro rather you start looking at okay
16 732 people a month are searching
directly and I also want to encourage
you never want to
these numbers are are sometimes hard to
interpret because
16 000 is actually a great number but
sometimes people are scared of only 457
but that's not really how YouTube works
that would just be 457 people typing in
like first apartment decorating but what
what this verifies for me is the intent
of people looking for decorating their
first apartment which by the way is at
the bottom of the list and maybe one of
my favorite ideas I'm like that's
amazing because first apartment is a
specific pain point a specific attempt
uh intent and so apartment decorating
hacks what I am just wanting to do is
verify intent but also look for
different angles and different ideas
modern architecture so perhaps as we dig
in here uh thrifted Furniture makeover
your topic you're tapping into a lot of
things there yet it looks like Morgan's
doing retro it could also be mid-century
modern thrifted comes into it and then
she's already a great Storyteller
thinking about maybe
something outrageous like entire
bedroom for under a hundred dollars or
just you know different things that
actually could be the makings of a
million viewed video and so that's the
uh keyword tool that you can find on vid
IQ and if you're interested in that hit
the link in the description as well or
go to vidiq.com forward slash think but
our next channel is
a singer it looks like Isabel and
she does vocal covers metal covers
if that's not for you try my other
covers by Queen John Legend Celtic Women
and 75 000 views on the channel
we have some shorts as much as 12 000
views on our most popular
and on our videos
we have
2 900 views on a cover video
uh
2500 on a medley of Epica which is
perhaps a metal band Celtic Women did
very well two years ago
and let's get a Vibe of this and kind of
see what kind of content she's creating
so right from the start Dan we could see
she definitely is got the tools for
audio incredible voice
she's got
I'm not sure if she's making the music
herself
beautiful though I will say
I
this isn't terrible as far as a hook
but a couple things I don't like that
there's like a bold stroke there's like
a stroke on the text and this font
is over stroked so that the letters
letters are touching and it's just
that's just kind of a pet peeve but I
don't it's not my favorite and then this
shot is
meant to be artistic but I think it
misses the mark
you've got like a Blue Yeti or whatever
this is maybe it's much nicer than that
you've got your pop filter
the shot composition like I think if we
saw the Dynamics of your face I think
it's a huge one your face is hidden and
it still could be kind of a dramatic
shot and then it's interesting I mean I
know the music is then we come here
said to me I am the voice of your
history so I know that people are here
for the music and you already looks like
I was a good camera you're good with the
editing you do have a couple different
angles
just a thought because we want to make
that intro so strong and it's the idea
in general would be like how can I open
on my strongest shot how could I open on
my most interesting shot how could I
open on the shot that would hold
people's attention how could I open up
on a shot that might make people say
it's kind of weird what's happening here
I can't look away I need to discover
more like just how could I
hold people's attention
um Dan any thoughts on this video and
then let me know if you want me to click
back over to the channel we'll start
looking at thumbnails and everything
else I agree with all your points on on
the video itself I I don't watch a lot
of channels that do like musical covers
so I was trying to think of do I have
any like advice in terms of like if you
should be doing a different hook like
maybe you should be talking before you
go into the singing I don't know I would
follow best practices there
um but uh what I was gonna say for the
whole Channel like I'm really impressed
by the amount of views they're getting
channels like this can be very difficult
like Advent IQ I don't know about you
guys but we get a lot of comments like
how do you like grow a music channel you
know music channels are just just a
tough space to be in and to see the
progress this channel had already is
really really encouraging
by the way this one is
10 times better it opens on water so
it's more interesting so I'm like okay
and obviously it's about the music it
opens on water though the text is nice
and clean a little bit larger and
the words aren't touching or that I
don't think that would have hurt
necessarily or helped the last video but
just just it seems a little cleaner
stronger beautiful shot and then this
shot combo of you up at the front I
think it was the pop filter that was is
so large that just overtook on top of
the mic uh in the last video but this is
amazing so
um okay and then I like the thumbnails
down what do you think
I generally speaking Yeah I I think
these are uh you know in line with what
I've seen a lot of music channels I
prefer the ones where it's like you and
then like the text on the nice clean
wall but those aren't performing as well
as some of these other ones
um yeah uh overall yeah I think these
are these are really strong I think
shorts if it looks like they have a
shorts tab that's something that I think
is like a super hack for music channels
it's time to last time yep
[Music]
imagine scrolling to this
you're you're on the YouTube short shelf
you're not looking for any specific kind
of music maybe this is the music you
like maybe it's not but you scroll to
this and someone is just immediately
hitting you in the face with their
talent like that's the kind of stuff
that gets people to stop scrolling and I
think they're leveraging shorts really
well even though they don't have like
you know this is the best one in 12 000
views still a pretty good amount of
views across all of these and it could
be very easily bringing views into the
long-form content since it's so so
similar yeah and I'm not sure what
the full music rights copyright
situation is but the nice thing is if
you're if you're somehow mixing this
music yourself
and covering a song
chances are in air quotes that
you're also you're you're good in terms
of monetization
um perhaps copyright
and that you should be fine the flip
side is if for some reason you also miss
out on monetization my argument for
music channels is like who cares it's
about the reach so even if it's like
monetization's limited you're like all
right whatever I still got 10 million
views on the short and that's about
exposure and a wellness awareness and so
what I think
um that leads me to think when I if I'm
you what you're already doing this
but you gotta tap into Trend surfing and
we talk about influence surfing and
Trend surfing both are big opportunities
for you and you're bringing as you said
covers to like metal bands which which
is uh its own massively popular
subculture
and it makes me think I mean on the one
hand it's your tube it's YouTube it's
your tube you can do whatever you want
it does make me think like if you tap
into
what bands are trending what songs are
trending what has the broadest appeal
even in it doesn't have to be super
broad appeal like it doesn't need to be
mainstream if you're on more of a niche
metal type of content but then you
really tap into if if a song from the
new Twilight movie from the new Harry
Potter like whatever like some type of
Whatever the song that everyone's
playing that and then that also hits
shorts and people go whoa but that's a
cool take on it I mean that definitely
is the recipe and what's
very encouraging is I mean you have an
amazing Vibe an amazing voice and you've
got your workflow down
it looks too like I mean we were looking
at some of the best performing but some
of these newer thumbnails they're
getting more Dynamic there's a little
more color a little more shadow in there
and it looks like even the hooks
we're having the
b-roll fade in and over her candle shop
what not
I'm curious and I don't know if
here right now I'm curious what the
soundtrack is where the music's from
and if it's just an instrumental and
we're gonna get flagged for that
instrumental when she is or it's G mixed
the song up
[Music]
at least from what I can see here
there's nothing
there's YouTube would pop up a thing
this content belongs to or this is that
it uh it's fine but like we're taking
the monetization or the artist or the
label or the distribution I do not only
writes to this song nor instrumental
thank you for the instrumental so it
came from this channel
um and
what's there's a good question that came
in that said
I don't know if this is wrong or it's
just literally their handle and they
have some other thing going on the
channel doesn't seem to be active there
but it is a real channel so so you got
this instrumental that person looks like
they have not uploaded it to Content ID
or claimed any rights on it because it
looks like you're not flagged with any
rights on it now
Isabel can't be monetized yet because we
don't have the subscribers yet and who
knows about the watch time but the
answer to your question was what I was
getting at are you able to monetize
covers
yes no or maybe next question no I'm
just I mean that's kind of true I mean I
think what we just described is is the
goal like maybe it doesn't oh here's the
actual song so
[Music]
if okay so if this channel uploaded this
this does look like a real CD cover
um and the vibe it gives me is like I'm
in the Connor
um Washington and I'm in a niche like
it's a Shabby Chic Downtown antique
shopping and I go into like this this
Niche bookstore used bookstore with my
wife my kids are playing outside eating
ice cream and they've got like this kind
of local artist collection of CDs and
um you know some really cool beautiful
instrumental like this also 1997 perhaps
the band broke up so it would be one of
those things where even this oh oh I
take it back
so this is what you would see so this
sees the music being flagged
okay
um so this is YouTube music Dan do you
agree I yeah I think this is YouTube
plugging it so so what What's Happening
Here with this song is they're saying
first of all I don't think the channel
is being penalized no big deal they're
just saying okay for whatever views this
gets
we see that and we're gonna attribute
that to the artist so even though this
came out in 1997 maybe they are still
together and maybe they aren't the
punchline is it just depends on maybe
how mainstream is the song
um who owns the rights is it uploaded to
YouTube's content ID saying all that
uploaded here with different vocals it
looks like it did not flag the ID system
this also becomes one of those things
where
you know our mutual friend Roberto Blake
just had like 50 videos from five years
ago all copyright stricken or they took
away the monetization because he was
using music that back then was royalty
free from Machinima
um which was a multi-channel network or
some kind that probably gave him the
music but if that company was acquired
and the rights of their back music
library were changed and then the rights
and the settings and some of this stuff
could like stress you out a couple
things I think one
um
don't be afraid the future is forward
take risks do things and just don't the
worst that's gonna happen is maybe you
lose monetization the bigger tip would
be
build your influence with great content
great videos great music but diversify
your income
because if you have diverse income
streams and you're not just relying on
YouTube monetization then again for like
an artist like this I don't know if she
has her own music or she wants to send
people to Spotify or someday she does
kind of a crowdfunding project because
you've built a lot of fans that's why
it's build your influence build up that
fan base even if you lose out because
you use an instrumental but YouTube
allows it to stay up
but they take the monetization to the
artist sometimes they split it with the
artist so just that's why the answer is
yes no and maybe yeah the copyright the
copyright holder is going to really be
the one to you know you're at the mercy
of them and gaming channels for example
um can fall prey to this in theory any
gaming video you see could be taken down
or or at least copyright you know can be
like attributed to the creator of the
game if the company who owns the game
wants to do that but a lot of companies
understand that they get a lot of
revenue from people making revenue on
YouTube so gaming is okay for now but
nothing is stopping copyright holders
going after any gaming channel you know
so it's kind of the same thing here you
you upload music that's not yours
yeah you know it depends on how the
record label feels about that
yep and it looks like Isabelle says the
band's still huge and active uh it looks
like that one didn't get flagged but I
used karaoke's in instrumentals for the
songs I sang and so uh incredible work
you've got a ton of talent a great
Channel I think definitely if depending
on when you join VRA I think um if you
go to VRA Masters I have deep dive
trainings on influence surfing and Trend
surfing I think there could be some big
growth keys and then Dan's advice though
I think just doubling and tripling down
on shorts
um and then you know these also I I
don't think this is clearly just did
very good but sometimes I think I do
think a little bit in terms of
production
and or even framing
um not a big deal but like it looks like
it's just the crop of the horizontal
video it does give you the nice empty
space to have the text show up clear so
in this case I think it actually works
incredibly powerful but even this one it
feels a little more dynamic
[Music]
so also
they this did very well and the hook of
the short though I think is a Miss yeah
I I started to start right there yes I
would have started on the word I've like
the most familiar you know and get a
syllable out like as fast as you can
yeah just instantly yeah and
because starting with the
black on screen empty text
or just the tags
yeah just with Ive and and then perhaps
you could simultaneously there is the
passion in your face there's the I've
we're hearing there's the essentially
the drop happening instantly it's like
the payoff happening immediately and we
talk about the hook being in a normal
video being 5 10 15 seconds 30 seconds a
minute in a short it's one second it's
like the first second one two three
seconds or someone's gonna swipe and so
the cool thing is perhaps I'm reading
the title
insinuating the topic oh cool a cover of
My Immortal by Evanescence
so they stay and you got 1 700 views but
it'd be fascinating in fact let me
challenge you this would be a fun
exercise I will be able to debrief on do
this today
um
let's take this short
and you're here live maybe you can do it
in the next hour
um trim off the beginning and just start
with Ive
[Music]
and let's uh and then re-upload it no
harm no foul don't worry about it being
slight like and
what I also wonder
is
I wouldn't put that either
not and there's nothing about the
description or nothing about subscribe
no I'm sorry yeah
no black screen on the beginning or in
the end yeah the end yup your face
immediately no fade no anything like
that I've and then get like as much as
you feel like you need in there and then
just hard cut out like and either and
you could either hard cut out
or knowing your
tempos and your or your measures or
whatever and knowing if it Loops back to
I've yep
then and the cut then then you just
leave that
and what I would potentially do though
is I would replace subscribe and full
link in the description with
um a little thumbs up like
if you want like I don't think that's
gonna hurt or or something and this is
without thinking too deeply because what
we just said if you just did that I
think it'd be great but you don't want
something to be triggered to go off the
video but a reminder to just like like
something easy like you know like for
Evanescence or you know just a thumbs up
button or something that would be an
option in the middle but for also
perhaps unnecessary so I can't wait to
do this test so we're going to start
with I've try to hit the loop
no indication of the video is ending
we'll see if that gets better than 100
audience retention because people Loop
and maybe also love it so we'll listen
to it again or just are tricked and so
they listen to it for a few more seconds
realizing it looped then no need to give
the call to action to this description
but you already got six comments on this
do a pinned comment
um to the full length video which is I
want to argue a thousand times better
than the description description's kind
of too hard to get to because notice I
have to go description I have to go
three dots description then I could get
to the link whereas people in shorts
read the comments during while watching
the short and it's a much easier place
to get to in a much more likely Place
they'd get to so you could you could pin
the full length version right now
um it in the description
real easy and think media is going to
comment on that right now but I like a
little finger pointy finger emoji
you know you could do something like
that pin that comment
and
what would be interesting is again you
may get more clicks from the short to
there especially because there's a call
to action here but that breaking of the
viewer session is not the main point or
the main goal I think that what will be
really cool is ultimately
no black on the front or back try to get
it to Loop don't say in the description
um let people subscribe if they want I
may or may not motivate them but just
let them enjoy the music and I'm so
excited and then um Isabelle's gonna do
this today
um and then you know let's give it a uh
three four five six seven days and then
let's see what happens
um and drop a report in in VRA maybe
break it down timing could have
something to do with it I don't think
your current subscribers are are going
to be bothered by it that's power tip
three of the day and that is this some
of my
YouTube shorts expert friends meaning
they emphasize shorts they upload two
three four five shorts a day and they've
grown millions of subscribers from
shorts
don't hesitate to upload the same short
a couple different times yeah they'll
re-hook it though sometimes they'll
complete like like the main content is
the same but they'll re-architect the
hook or the timing and I'm not
suggesting that that's something you
need to do but in this case I think
there's only upside and opportunity
reusing the content that you have and
this came out January 21st no one's even
going to remember a couple new
subscribers came they might just be
pumped to hear it again but what could
be really interesting is you also now
when you if you do it on mobile you
could select the thumbnail this is a
good thumbnail because of the passion
there
um but uh yeah I'm excited for that I
did want to say this and this would be
the final thing I was thinking we're
really giving some tactical stuff on one
short but if for anybody listening to
this every nuanced detail we're getting
here I think could be helpful I think
that this is
will capture enough in terms of like
the video filter the color grading
however
it's not super Punchy I don't think what
I'm saying is going to make or break it
but when I look down a little bit and I
saw this other one
this this was just it was punchier to me
it this the the saturation and the
Vibrance feels higher the the purplish
tones it makes the plain white wall just
it doesn't it's not so muted and it just
is more gripping more striking so one
other thing you know we're going crazy
literally the easiest thing would be to
take this video download it throw it in
an editor trim the ends and then that's
like level one but if you decide how
deep you want to go with this uh but
ultimately you could throw a different
grade on it if you had the original
thing in your um uh
you know Adobe Premiere filmora or
iMovie or wherever you edit and we went
really deep there Dan but let me know
um if you're getting any unlocks or aha
moments think media podcast Community uh
smash like if you're getting value that
was sort of some tactical short
opportunities and the opportunity to
perhaps give your short a second chance
hashtag give your short a second chance
shorts need Second Chances Dan they do
I've I've done it myself and I took old
shorts I'm like this didn't do super
well but I still think it's funny and
I've reposted them not only did my
subscribers not notice like the long
time viewers people got more comments
got more views people were excited uh
not a single comment saying I remember
this what are you doing
um so yeah you can absolutely re-upload
it and not take down the old one and I
also my last tip for that channel and
any music channel is if you can find
more like current songs too I think
that's a very that's like a song
everybody knows if they if they follow
that genre of music but as you're going
forward like can you do that same
treatment to a brand new trending song
uh because that is also like a super tip
to grow as a music channel that's doing
covers and things like that always make
sure it's within your genre within your
zone of expertise but uh you know keep
following those trends
so good and I think that brings us to
our opportunity cooking with singles is
wondering how foul are down the rabbit
hole do you want to go
do you want to take the blue pill
or the pink pill you decide
it's too cheesy but I just got inspired
and I had sticky notes on my desk
um Dan do you have a few more minutes
yes I don't have a prop budget like you
but I do have a few more minutes amazing
um okay Austin asks any advice for
pivoting channels I do gaming but I
don't play the game that got the bulk of
My Views
oh okay uh some music I got confused uh
so pivoting any channel any topic is
always difficult you can absolutely
switch gears and do something else with
the understanding though that whoever
was following you before
understand that they may not follow you
to the next thing some of them might you
know and that's the goal right some some
people will follow you but you're gonna
have people drop off and I would go into
that as as like a just be conscious of
that and go that's okay the idea is that
I'm going to start off kind of slow but
I'm going to get new viewers based on
the new thing that I'm doing and that
I'm passionate about uh and then one
thing is if your old content is still
bringing in a lot of new viewers that's
when I would ask you to maybe consider
either a totally different Channel or to
unlist those old videos because what's
going to happen is people are going to
subscribe for the old stuff which you're
not doing anymore and then they're going
to see the new stuff and not click and
that just kind of slows you down because
you get a lot of you get a nice initial
Boost from YouTube when you put up
something brand new and it goes up to
your super fans and they click on it but
if your super fans aren't clicking on it
it just kind of slows you down so that's
what I would go into whether I don't
care if you're gaming I don't care if
you're you know Travel Channel whatever
it is like that's the understanding you
have to have is you attracted a certain
type of viewer and you might be moving
away from what they're interested in
powerful tips
okay
a couple channels we'll call this the
lightning round we're looking at
casually sharp multimedia which is an
interesting angle and I would say the
channel topic is
casually is sharing your memories so it
feels like video tips I mean it is video
tips
um selfies
but the angle is kind of like how to
make your family photos and videos
amazing so a very niche
angle because there are those who maybe
do not Aspire many who do not aspire to
be a YouTube Creator or to upload their
videos on YouTube or to be a filmmaker
but they want to capture life's memories
so it seems that there's a clear
audience in everyday life we want to
have milestones and events
um what's also kind of cool about this
is when you really understand
like you want to understand the pain
points and desires of your audience
everybody watching this
for the YouTube Creator I'm sure many
here you want a silver play button or a
thousand subscribers or a gold play
button or to get monetized but then you
think about the person who's like I just
want to figure out how to use my camera
or figure out how to share they don't
want to so so what is it they really
want and I think that um
giving them the tools and oftentimes the
wind being like I couldn't get my camera
to look right and you help me get it to
look right I couldn't actually transfer
and I couldn't it makes me think of
transferring from VHS to digital how do
you capture different tools uh and my
initial thought is I know we're just
starting here I do see that you're
already getting like fancy over here at
least in the thumbnail with a Canon DSLR
it looks like in a giant lens and
I having as you know probably quite a
bit of depth in my own Tech experience I
actually think you have a wide open
opportunity
to lean into
camcorders
like camcorders are the most slept on
camera
because all the I would argue
hipster
YouTube creators want mirrorless cameras
dslrs very few people talk about
camcorders furthermore
when you empathetically understand which
I believe you do because you say this in
your about page
like the problem with a lot of
mirrorless cameras even if they try to
make them easy like this Sony zv1 and
you know tools like that is they're not
that easy to use and they don't give you
a little hand grip and flip out the
screen and film the soccer game and I
don't want to change my lens and then
zoom in 45x to film The goal of the kids
and so
the riches are in the niches
and I think that
um leaning into that type of thing as
well as and I'm sure some people will do
it do it but like how to
transfer VHS
to digital and there's probably some
different tools and there could be
product review things 486 590 75 and
this little tool right here you could do
a tool this was three months ago and it
got 166 000 and it only has a 15 000
views on the channel so if you think
about even pain points again like really
leaning into this kind of stuff
and
if we could get a a price here like even
this person looks like this is doing
pretty good with 39 000 views but as I
look at them like
like Elgato capture card
my neighbor Frank is not gonna use an
ogato capture card he's not gonna put a
capture like an internal pcie capture
card in anything he's gonna probably use
some of these top tools so like
cheap and easy Amazon
like device Gadget
to help you capture and then
and then camcorders best camcorder
23.
so and and then thinking budget so the
budget buyers guide here this is
interesting this would be a faceless
Channel I can spot them a Milo hey guys
in this video we're going to look at the
top five best 4K Captain Quarters two
years old actually they changed the
title its own tip
um two years ago
so whatever year that was 2021 they
called it 2023. so you could probably
make a better video that's more current
this also reveals that you don't have to
buy all five camcorders because you
could take you are on camera or it's
going to be your voiceover but this week
it's been I I said lightning round Dan
what are we doing I forgot you said that
we're getting kind of tactical here but
again this faceless Channel AKA YouTube
automation Channel or whatever is all
probably written by vid iq's AI coach
script meets you know some b-roll from
the manufacturer which is very
fascinating in all the affiliate links
but my point to say here would be
um
you know
camcorders and
this also says budget
which was these things that we see this
all the time I talk about this Nolan and
Omar
there's so much bad information on the
internet like we have so much work to do
eight
1848 is not budget for for the average
person you know that wants to go film
their soccer game they really want to
get the biggest impact for and you can
start talking about you can have
affiliate links to eBay and some
different things
but yeah this is the rank video it's not
the best answer to the question and what
actually what gets us fired up is we we
want to launch a whole blog vid IQ has
got an incredible blog two writers great
information a whole nother conversation
about search engine optimization and
growing in terms of that written content
but when we look up friends and please I
warn you we look up like best camera for
YouTube 2023 and there's ranked blog
post they're terrible they say things
like gh5
the heaviest no autofocus Panasonic like
for vlogging they'll say about like the
best camera and I'm like what are we
talking about they'll say g7x Mark III
again horrible autofocus back focus is
weird these are not good answers or
they'll talk about some smaller cameras
that do terrible and low light and
you're like the person would use this
alone they want to film concerts at
night
I'm getting a little fired up like I
literally just got triggered But
ultimately
what we're after is empathy for
the viewer understanding of the viewer
and you've got a zillion topics to go
really deep I think in this Niche but I
want to also challenge you to continue
to get to know them better and don't be
afraid of sometimes we call it the
a-s-ssq strategy answer stupid simple
specific questions
because the person grandma wants to film
Christmas
and she's not gonna be like changing
lenses on an M50 and like plugging in a
road mic like she
needs a simpler solution
I need you making videos for Grandma
Dan a great text
great tip uh your video quality looks
amazing your thumbnail quality needs
work
uh just a cold hard truth there uh I I
think the thumbnails are
it's it's not that they are not
communicating a message like I could see
where you're going with what you know
you're really trying to communicate that
clear message but we really got to level
up the quality of the thumbnails for
example the latest video I see you try
to do maybe like a rule of thirds thing
but it's kind of not translating too
well you're in Focus the camera's in
focus and the people in the background
are in Focus everything's in focus and
so it just kind of looks flat and it
doesn't really like give me The Vibes I
need also when you're reviewing cameras
you're not in that picture but like
you're it's not my family photos but
like it almost you're you're straight in
front of the lens like the camera is
pointed at the lens does that make sense
so it can't really tell what kind of
camera it is because we're not getting a
nice side profile or like a 45 degree
profile from it so it just kind of when
you're scrolling through YouTube really
quick it just looks like a a black blob
on the thumbnail like you got to think
about people looking at this really fast
and trying to make decisions about what
they're going to watch so video quality
this looks great it's the thumbnail
quality for me that definitely needs to
be leveled out
I think that we've shared a lot here and
I want to encourage you the ingredients
you have you've got your studio going
you've uh built your and you're building
you communicate you've got your energy
you've got your gear I can tell you've
got the knowledge all of this all these
ingredients make sure that you uh now
just kind of take it to the next level
and I hope that
uh some of the things I just shared kind
of spinning off on on video topics then
it's a matter of I think just getting
back to it and what I mean by that is
I mean four years ago you uploaded a
video now we're back at it which is
great okay I don't know you know what we
all go through different seasons and
whatnot but on the other side of
50 answer stupid simple specific
questions videos helping people solve
these problems and what I would guess I
would guess
that
sometimes it's just kind of one thing
it's like one like
how to actually turn the audio on the
such and such camera and and and one of
the biggest ways to solve problems is to
kind of scratch your own Edge that's an
intuition that helped me in my career
is is noticing aspects of things that
could turn into a video
um one of which was like there was an
old uh task car mic so you'd find like a
popular shotgun mic so the task car mic
was this incredible uh
microphone for twenty dollars twenty
five dollars or something like that I
don't even know if they sell it anymore
but
the way that it's headphone input worked
was it was like mono because it only had
one it's like tip ring ring s what does
the S stand for
I don't know I know what you're talking
about though trrs
what's that stand for
hip ring ring sleeve if anybody was
curious now we're getting super we're
getting more geeky so you can see on any
little audio cables like this right uh
trrs uh is like smartphone because you
have you have like left right and
microphone for a smartphone whereas a
microphone only needs
only needs two not three of these guys
so TRS versus trrs here's the point that
microphone uh that shotgun mic you'd
record and it was only on one channel
unless you just got this 99 cent
connector that made it two channels so
as I I was like this is dumb and this is
a video idea and if other people are
frustrated there's probably people over
the next five years that'll be looking
for this and if they're looking for this
they'll
click the one dollar affiliate link
which won't actually be a lot of money
but if you click Amazon for 24 hours you
get anything and then the video gets 55
000 views over five years it gets a lot
of clicks it sells a ton of like one
dollar things which I make two cents but
then every once in a while a camcorder
comes in and I'm like whoa and I started
to build momentum so your Niche is very
relevant for just like def little geeky
tips tools specific which could also be
helpful for all of us here because
when you're also building out like deep
dive 11 minute videos that need to have
multi-parts there's also just the
opportunity to answer like one specific
question like
big media like change hard drive of a
Toshiba laptop I had a laptop I wanted
to change the hard drive I don't know if
I'll be able to find this there it is
here's old Sean 10 years ago 86 000
views uh how to add RAM in an SSD
to allow to add just four gigabytes of
RAM now I'm shooting one stick change
camera now when I got this computer it
had two phones
they have a different laptop it doesn't
matter because they might look at it
compare it click the links
this video is right
disk
remember the operating system here we
are so anyways getting into different
and so you can pitch specific videos
on screen right now these uh talking
about how to how to do hard drives and
then booting it back up
you're looking like Nolan and Omar's
videos and I'm out here
but hey so check that out people are
there for the content value hey what's
up Sean here in this video as much the
production value although in a 2023
World things have changed probably a bit
and so production value matters but if
you help them add the RAM and upgrade
the SSD and by the end of the video
they're like it worked then you're going
to have a satisfied viewer and that's
what YouTube wants since they're in the
job of helping
satisfy viewers we're Landing the plane
here as we approach the 90 minute mark
um but Dan
if anybody wants to connect with what
you guys are doing how can they find you
uh vid IQ just type in vid IQ into
YouTube search we'll come right up and
uh if you're looking for General YouTube
growth advice uh you know check it out
we're trying all kinds of new content
formats and things like that too we're
trying to talk to more creators and uh
it's it's been a lot of fun so yeah
check out vid IQ if you get a chance
amazing and day I'd appreciate all your
advice shared a lot of powerful tips
today and always love it when we have
you on the think media podcast and if
you want to check out today uh vid IQ
this stream has been brought to you by
vid IQ you can get a 30-day trial of vid
iq's boost plan for just a dollar if you
go to vidiq.com forward slash think
super great deal I mean it's just a
dollar and
um you can start tapping into the
powerful tools including the new AI
coach and so this tool is immensely
powerful why I love it is there is a
basic version which if you have a brand
new channel no data yet you could get
started
but if you go to the advanced Channel
data it's personalized to you meaning
that IQ actually connects to your
Channel
and then
is able to analyze your videos and
analytics so then you can have these
Diamond prompts here on the right that
have a little Diamond next to them that
means they are advanced
prompts that are influenced because if
you just say how do I get views for
example that generic question would not
be personalized to you but because vid
IQ is connected to my channel think
media I can click how do I get views and
it's thinking about my question in
relation
to the data the views the subs the
growth of
my channel so it says it's thinking
about the question it's looking at my
YouTube channel data and what we're
going to see is now specific advice so I
can make some data driven decisions but
also so it can simplify things for me
so here's the AI coach hey there I've
analyzed your channel think media and
its performance overall in the last uh
and its performance in the last 30 days
I've also tested this out and asked to
ask it questions like
can you give like base it on the last 90
days based on different time frames so
what's really fun is like getting to
know AI coach this will be like your
best YouTube friend
so it's breaking down some things on my
target audience right now
uh talking about where
um viewership is and again it's pulling
this data out of my analytics but what
I've found so helpful is like make
complex things simple here's why I love
vidiq make complex things simple so I
can make quick decisions make my next
best video so I don't have to use my
decision making willpower and all my
brain power trying to figure out what
the next best move is to make where I
could actually just top tap into this
tool
and start getting some really cool
results and so talking about our primary
audience suggestions research popular
Trends and topics within this age group
to create content that resonates with
them smart so okay what's 18 to 34
thinking about good question also
primarily mail we're about 75 percent
male on our other channel think media
we're streaming this right now on the
think media podcast but let's check this
out based on your top performing videos
your audience enjoys content related to
video editing YouTube growth and AI
tools for creators
hmm
suggestion create more videos on these
topics such as top 10 video editing tips
for beginners and how to use AI to boost
your channel growth right there
game over make those two videos next
we've taken obviously AI is blowing up
and we've taken the AI thing to heart
and we're trying to double down on that
we're testing a lot of different tools
literally we're using AI tool right now
we're obsessed with AI right now it is a
game changer you got to be tapping into
tools like this
um talking about the best engagement
also on our most recent tenants saying
AI tools uh optimal upload frequency
this will be interesting
over the last 30 days you've uploaded
five videos it's not true
um
consider uploading more frequently now
notice it says at the bottom here be
aware this is the Alpha version of AI so
it's not always going to answer as
expected however it is suggesting we go
one to two per week so I think I think
with shorts we do about one a day so
however it's pulling that data it missed
it on that one
number five video length your recent
videos have an average view percentage
rating of 30 that would be right to
fifty percent consider experimenting
with different video links and formats
great tips so this is all by the way
just one of the personalized prompts
that actually analyzes your channel
it'll audit your channel for you
it will say based on my channel what
video ideas do you have you can do a
channel analysis audience engagement how
can I increase my channel subscriber
count what types of videos do my
subscribers like most how can I improve
my audience retention rate
so this is again a brand new vid IQ
feature and it's really just the tip of
the iceberg of so many other things if
all you got was that tool it would be
worth the one dollar uh jumping in to
try it out but when you think about
daily ideas AI title recommendations
this view of daily ideas also
personalized to your channel the
um AI content generator it it's it's
there's some beta stuff right now on
generating thumbnails for you and this
is coming up with
the angle the length all kinds of very
unique nuances we were talking about the
keyword tool earlier so I have been a
massive fan and user of vid IQ
I don't know if finite gives better
route for a decade
basically from the start I'm 16 years on
YouTube think media is 10 years old this
channel is only three years old
um but I've been using vid IQ from like
the beginning I remember meeting Rob the
founder at vidsummit
one Daryl Eves has an event called
vidsummit I think it's on like year ten
seven or eight at the first one I think
we uh met and I was already like it's so
nice to meet you I'm a user of your tool
um and it's been cool to see that they
continue to add more cool things so if
you want to take your YouTube game to
the next level and you haven't tried out
vid IQ and all of these Cool Tools so
much more than we could cover definitely
grab take advantage of the one dollar
offer that they have going on right now
bidiq.com forward slash think or there's
a link in the description down below
and smash like if you are getting value
out of today's training
um I want to thank you for um being here
vid some of this year
Iowa team is going
the bearded I.T dad
I am being very selective with my
calendar my calendar is oddly packed
it's not odd obviously it's my decision
but I'm being I'm trying to eliminate
things from my Calendar personal life
updates wise because of having our eight
month old and our two and a half year
old and so whether it's different
speaking I am going to VidCon I'm
speaking at VidCon
um we're actually at Dave Ramsey's
entree leadership next week as an
executive team so I've had to say no to
a lot of events there's maybe a chance
I'll be there but I don't think I'm
going to be there saying that Nolan Omar
Steph Kyle Nathan I think are all going
to be there Draya perhaps
um are going to vidsummit this year
that's our plan
um and then vid IQ
grow with video our event is coming back
next year so that's you have a ton of
time that's it's about a year out so
you're hearing it here first it comes
back I think May 20
24 Las Vegas excited for that and uh I
want to thank you for being a part of
our community Ray hit it is it
t-r-s-t-r-r-s and t r r s he's right
it's mono stereo and microphone I think
is the ours the Rings am I right Ray if
you're still here
it's mono
right and left and then the extra ring
is because
you know your your Apple not airpods but
your corded Apple headphones that plug
into the dongle
those have a microphone on them that's
why you need the three R's if you made
it this far in the video
for the power tip number four or five
knowing
your microphone Jack tips
this is the big size of headphones
there's two rings on there
right
tip ring ring sleeve
left and right because there's left and
right on the headphones if there was a
third ring I could have a microphone if
there was only one ring it wouldn't be
stereo it'd be mono
and I'll tell you how much pain that's
caused me over the years of like
connecting this thing to that thing
that's why these days a lot of
microphones on Amazon are coming with
um two cables
so like there's a new Shore shotgun
microphone that I love I think I'm using
it here somewhere
um
and uh
is it sure
is it
right
we'll share it with you Sennheiser
so this Sennheiser uh shotgun microphone
one of my faves purchased two times yes
that is true I have purchased this two
times
and it comes it comes with two blue
cables one of the blue cables is trrs to
t r r s why are we even going you can
see the two cables there uh another one
is
the MKE 400 is where portability is for
smartphones so basically it's for your
DSLR because you don't need that it
could even mess it up if you've ever
plugged in a shotgun microphone and
you've been like more space it's not it
it it's not working on my camera or it's
only on one side like knowing your TRS
trrs
workflow is important and so one of
these is RR left and right RR and one
has got left and right because on the
microphone side
it's
the same
but on the smartphone side it needs that
extra T RRS so even plug what side of
the cable you plug into the mic and that
might all sound overwhelming but as soon
as you learn some of these things you
start
um being able to troubleshoot and it
could be incredibly helpful and
eliminate a lot of frustration the MKE
and so uh
yes
it is a great mic I I do love that Mike
it's really really good sounds great and
it's cool because it's you sometimes you
need modern tools like that because
you're like why doesn't my microphone
work work with my smartphone or things
like that and Tom this mic is I believe
called the uh the Amazon
not called Amazon
all the uh Shure mv51
yep and Tom we'll link up uh we'll link
up the Shure mv51 in the description
um for those who are a fan of this mic
that I use it is very cool because it
has that really cool retro look to it
and that's also you're hearing this
microphone right now a little spendy but
I would always shop around
places
perhaps
refurbished perhaps
whatever but if you want the look it
looks like
it's 50 off right now that's pretty cool
it's 20 off and there's a oh there's the
promotion is Amazon music okay so
anyways that's this mic very great Mike
you then I then have the boom arm on it
I am a very poppy speaker I speak with a
lot of plosives
so you don't need this pop filter that I
have right here you don't you don't need
it and if I speak thoughtfully it's
probably not a problem but because I'm
so plosive e which is usually the peas
when you're speaking
I put this uh pop filter in front of it
so I could double down little road boom
arm and man you're off to the races this
is a USB microphone so we'll we'll throw
that in if you want to check out the
direct link if you want that'll be our
affiliate Link in the description and
then if you want to check out that uh
Sennheiser mic and and you're looking
for it's these aren't necessarily the
best budget options or whatever
um
but
they are
amazing and I can fully endorse them
no sponsorship
I but I would get sponsored Sennheiser
we've worked with sure before so
Sennheiser please email me and sure
let's get a deal going again but I am
just telling you some of the tools that
I love to use
and um
we'll we'll actually see that one as
well so that is the
MKE 400 if you want an on-camera shotgun
mic that is also
um you you need kind of a wild rig not a
wild but you need a if you're going to
mount it somewhere I want to use it for
a smartphone but I actually use this
with a Joby with this little Smartphone
holder that has a place for the mic to
mount and then I use it so I use it with
my smartphone on a Joby GorillaPod for
kind of like more Pro smartphone
photography but obviously the better use
case for me I put it on my Canon R6
anyways we'll link both of those up in
the description down below smash like
for the tips today if you just joined
watch the replay we covered a couple
different Channel topics shout out to
the VRA fam for the channels we reviewed
today
and Shout Out massive love to you for
being a part of the stream appreciate
you the carriage house thanks for being
a part of our community
um thank you for uh
the support of the channel I recognize
we would not be able to do what we do I
wouldn't be blessed to be sitting in
this position if you weren't here
sharing your love your attention
smashing like and so literally from the
bottom of my heart I'm humbled every day
to just think about the honor and the
privilege it is to get to create content
for a living and so thank you for that
and that is also our passion at think
media we're on a mission to help one
million purpose-driven people create a
full-time living doing what they love
while making a difference in the world
with YouTube and so appreciate you
thanks for being here my name is Sean
Cannell rhymes with YouTube channel and
I look forward to seeing you on the next
stream